[Música]
el 31 de agosto de 1888 aparece
cruelmente descuartizado en las calles
de nueva york el cuerpo de una mujer
a los pocos días la policía recibe una
nota reivindicativa con el seudónimo de
jack el destripador la policía los días
siguientes siguió recibiendo nuevas
notas y se siguieron también produciendo
nuevos crímenes que llevaban en el
crimen mismo la firma de jack el
destripador en noviembre de ese mismo
año había sobre la mesa del jefe de
policía de scotland yard 150 notas
reivindicativas unas verdaderas y otras
falsas la policía se vio absolutamente
incapaz de procesar toda aquella
información de hecho empezó a seguir
hasta 5 pistas falsas e hizo cinco
retratos robot totalmente incoherentes
porque pertenecían los sospechosos a
clases sociales muy diferentes entre sí
desde un barbero a un descargador del
puerto un profesor de dos por un pintor
de la alta sociedad sin embargo
en muy poco tiempo una profesora en un
artículo muy reciente
aplicando la inteligencia artificial y
algunos de los algoritmos con los que
trabajamos en lingüística para estudiar
el estilo de los textos consiguió
separar las notas falsas de las
verdaderas y trazar el perfil exacto del
criminal si esto hubiera podido tenerlo
la policía este señor hubiera sido bueno
señor hubiera sido detenido en muy poco
tiempo pero con aquellos medios no
fueron capaces digo de procesar esa
información el perfil
bernal nos distingue a cada uno de
nosotros de la persona que tenemos al
lado nadie
hablamos exactamente igual al otro los
filólogos nos referimos a esto como
idiolecto cada uno tenemos nuestro
propio idiolecto y éste idiolecto nos
distingue igual que nos distingue la
huella dactilar o nos distingue el adn
y da igual que intentemos ocultar el
idiolecto detrás de un alias o detrás de
un avatar
da igual que intentemos imitar el estilo
de otra persona porque la mayor parte de
los procesos que se producen a la hora
de elaborar un discurso oral o escrito
son procesos que se escapan de nuestro
control son procesos no voluntarios
yo soy profesor de literatura y en mis
años de estudiante allá en finales de
los 70 se puso de moda una teoría que
hablaba de la muerte del autor y nada
menos que la patrocinada en roland
barthes y michel foucault personalidades
de absoluto respeto lo tenían entonces
por parte de mis condiscípulos y lo
siguen teniendo hoy también por parte
mía de la muerte del autor venía a decir
que una vez producido el texto el texto
estaba ahí el autor desaparecía no tenía
ya ningún tipo de relevancia sin embargo
aquella teoría a mí no me convencía
porque cuando yo me enfrentaba a la
lectura de un libro como el quijote de
avellaneda firmado por un seudónimo o
como el lazarillo o como el primer acto
de la celestina detrás de cada palabra
detrás de cada frase se me aparecía la
imagen del autor es verdad que no podía
ponerle nombre a esa imagen pero también
es verdad que se convertía en algo
familiar para mí yo podía saber que era
que este hombre que había escrito
aquello había leído o que era lo que
pensaba en relación con él eras mismo en
relación con cualquier otra doctrina o
ideología de aquel momento otra pregunta
que siempre me surgía era cuando me
enfrentaba con la lectura de obras
firmadas por un heterónimo por ejemplo
obras de antonio marchado pero que
antonio machado se las atribuye a juan
de mairena o como la cantidad de obras
de fernando pessoa que atribuye a campos
oa reyes y mi pregunta era quién está
detrás de ese lenguaje de quién es el
idiolecto del autor que los creó o del
personaje ficticio que este autor había
creado y la verdad es que en aquellos
momentos no disponíamos la filología no
disponía de herramientas para dar otra
respuesta que no fuera la mera hipótesis
o la conjetura
sin embargo en 1996 ocurrió algo que por
lo menos para mí cambió mi manera de
entender la literatura y mi manera de
relacionarme con ella ese año yo estaba
dictando un curso de doctorado en la
universidad de california y se produjo
un acontecimiento literario importante
sobre los estantes de las librerías
apareció un libro titulado primary
colors que
enseguida causó un enorme impacto y que
desaparecía con la misma velocidad con
la que los camiones eran capaces de
llevarlos a las librerías todo el mundo
quería leer ese libro que razón que era
lo que motivaba el interés por este
libro pues este libro trataba de los
últimos años del mandato de bill clinton
aquellos en donde mónica lewinsky tuvo
un protagonismo importante
pero ciertamente no fue el morbo lo
único que convirtió a este libro en un
best seller también fue el hecho de que
apareciera firmado tal y como lo ven
ustedes en esa portada anonymous el
hecho de que este libro que trataba de
un tema tan candente no se supiese quién
era el autor despertó enseguida el
interés de todos los periódicos desde la
costa este a la costa oeste y todos
ellos se disputaban por ver cuál era el
primero que conseguía dar con el nombre
que estaba detrás de ese anonymous cada
periódico tenía su candidato y con
frecuencia los candidatos de un
periódico no coincidían con el candidato
del periódico rival el problema parecía
irresoluble hasta que un modesto
profesor donald foster propone un nombre
joel klein
y hoy klein era en aquel momento un
columnista muy prestigioso de la revista
newsweek amigo personal de bill clinton
que lo había acompañado en alguno de sus
últimas campañas y él negó rotundamente
la paternidad de ese libro esto le causó
muchos problemas al al profesor sin
embargo dos años más tarde en 1998 en
una editorial en una pequeña editorial
de chicago el editor mientras se está
moviendo en la mesa ordenando los
papeles y cambiando de un lugar a otro
el dinero de papeles que tenía sobre la
mesa se encuentra con un manuscrito que
se titula prime [ __ ] los que lleva la
firma manuscrita tiempos autógrafa de
joe klein
como llegó este profesor a dar con este
nombre de una manera tan exacta pues
sirviéndose de la inteligencia
artificial de ciertos algoritmos con los
que trabaja la estilo metería no sé si
hay muchos en la sala que conozcan qué
es la estilo metría lo voy a definir tal
y como se la defino a mis estudiantes la
estilo metría viene a ser para el
estudio de la literatura y para el
estudio de la lengua en general viene a
ser algo así como el análisis de sangre
para un médico el análisis de sangre al
médico le permite tener sobre la mesa a
la hora de emitir un diagnóstico un
elemento objetivo cuantificable y
replicable con lo cual puede ayudar su
intuición y su propia experiencia esto
es lo que ocurre con la estilo metri a
la espirometría nos permite medir hasta
75 parámetros diferentes de un texto
muchos de ellos insisto
se producen de una forma inconsciente y
no voluntaria este sería una muestra
verdad de algunos de los elementos que
mide la estilo metería y en todo se
parece a un análisis a un análisis de
sangre la espirometría permitió que la
voz del filólogo saliera a la calle y
que la voz del filólogo se enfrentara
con la palabra en otro contexto
diferente al de los textos y esto es muy
importante porque después de esas fechas
a las que he hecho alusión anteriormente
yo he trabajado como perito lingüista
como perito filólogo en casos de acoso
en casos de suplantación de personalidad
en casos de falsificación en casos de
plagio y yo jamás me hubiera atrevido a
dar ese salto del libro a la calle sin
una herramienta fiable y objetivable
como la que acabo de describir porque en
última instancia si yo me equivoco a
leer el quijote cervantes no va a
protestar pero si me equivoco a la hora
de emitir un juicio sobre un caso de
acoso las cosas se complica
y eso es lo que me dio fuerza para
emprender más allá de los libros un
trabajo también diferente en la vida y
aprovechar los conocimientos de la
literatura para llevarlos a la vida y no
he sido el único porque como verán al
llamado asesino de las pomas es un
lingüista el que el que lo detiene en
esencia se trata de un crimen la víctima
es una mujer a la que le roban el móvil
y desde el móvil con posterioridad se
envía un whatsapp a distintos clientes
de esta mujer bastó con que un lingüista
analizarse aquellos whatsapp para ver
que simplemente por la colocación de las
comas aquellos no pertenecían a esta
mujer sino que pertenecían al asesino lo
mismo el caso del unabomber un
terrorista norteamericano que enviaba
cartas bomba a universidades y centros
de aviación la policía lo llevaba
persiguiendo dos años no tenía ninguna
pista
ninguna de las agencias policiales de
eeuu hasta que un lingüista analizando
el manifiesto que le había enviado a uno
de los periódicos supo que este hombre
había estudiado en chicago que este
hombre tenía una edad precisa y que este
hombre se llamaba theodore kaczynski y
así fue inmediatamente detenido
recientemente en el país acaba de salir
esta noticia
la policía sabe con un 91 por ciento si
nuestra denuncia es verdadera o falsa y
todo esto basado en un análisis en un
análisis lingüístico el porvenir de los
estudios filológicos más allá del libro
es realmente esplendoroso y creo que nos
espera un gran reto en concreto sería
muy bueno que tuviéramos un diccionario
de emociones en español porque ese
diccionario nos permitiría algo que los
ingleses ya pueden hacer y que todavía
nosotros no que es por ejemplo
diagnosticar precozmente casos de
depresión o posibles
y además de esto puede emplearse en el
terreno de la política y ha sido
empleado para elaborar en las con la
comunidad autónoma de madrid los
programas del año 2015 y recientemente
todos ustedes recuerdan la noticia el
día 5 de septiembre aparece un artículo
anónimo en el 'new york times' acusando
a trump pues la forma de buscar al autor
de ese artículo el camino más rápido
desde luego será el de la filología
las palabras nos delatan las palabras
querámoslo o no aunque intentemos
ocultarnos aunque intentemos escondernos
en un avatar dejan al desnudo lo que
pensamos lo que sentimos lo que somos
ahí tienen la frase del unabomber la
frase que lo delató una frase que sólo
una persona bueno mejor dos
solo dos personas en el mundo podían
haberla pronunciado así
el autor definitivamente no ha muerto el
autor está vivo en sus escritos y la
aventura de descubrirlo es una aventura
apasionante lo fue para mí desde el
primer día en que un libro cayó en mis
manos pero seguro que esta experiencia
la comparto con la mayoría de la sala lo
que ocurre es que hoy mi manera de leer
ha cambiado digamos que se ha hecho más
responsable porque una palabra la manera
de enfrentarme yo con la palabra hoy no
puede ser exactamente la misma la
palabra no solamente es una cuestión de
estética o una cuestión de imaginación
porque en la vida fuera de los libros la
palabra compromete nuestro prestigio
nuestro honor nuestro dinero y en
algunos casos nuestra vida muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]